قال وزير العدل التركي الستون ان تحقيقا
قضائيا فتح ضض اللاعب الاسرائيلي في فريق
انطاليا سبور ذا كيف جيزك بتهمه التحريض
على الكراهيه بسبب تصرفاته الداعمه للمذبح
الاسرائيليه في غزه بحسب تعبيره وكانت
الشرطه التركيه قد اوقفت اللاعب على خلفيه
احتفاله بهدف سجله في مباراه لفريقه في
الدوري التركي قبل ان تفرج عنه اظهر فيه
شعارا يتضامن مع المحتجزين الاسرائيليين
في غز ما دفع فريقه الى
استبعاده وتوالت تصريحات المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين قبل الافراج عن اللاعب
التركي اذ وصف وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يف
جلنت اعتقاله بالامر الشائن المنطوي على
النفاق وقال جلنت على منصه اكس ان تركيا
تعمل كذراع تنفيذيه لحركه حماس وفق تعبيره
من نجاتي قال وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي تمار بن كفير ان تركيا تعمل
اسرائيل وحث الاسرائيليين على مقاطعتها
بتجنب السفر اليها او شراء
منتجاتها